[Music]
Merry Christmas and come back soon
hey boss you know they just was speaking
contest you're always talking about ha
ha the royal family of Belgravia invites
you to compete in our Christmas baking
competition ok we'll leave it
[Music]
Christmas is a magical time of you I
just wish I had someone to spend it with
Christmas wishes have been known to come
true I am so sorry
no problem who are you Oh Lady Margaret
Delacorte that's Duchess Montanaro Stacy
denovo I think we were destined to run
into each other I'm supposed to marry
Prince Edward on New Year's Day but I
hate being in the spotlight I want to
get to know what it's like to be a
normal girl
I want to switch places with you switch
places I become you and you become me
get out lonely be for two days no one
would even notice
Stacy bonobo how's it hangin how's it
hanging a [ __ ] marches it I suppose
it's the time if you say so
oh who you are Here I am
I'm determined to spend as much time
together as we can over the next few
days how smashing never burn anything I
guess I'm a bit nervous with the big
contest coming up
[Music]
all right but close eye on the Duchess
she seems um
different oh uh terribly sorry that
wasn't very dignified it's all right
I liked it actually Christmas should be
about that I've never seen you so
sentimental maybe you don't know me that
well
I didn't think things would get so
complicated so what do we do
[Music]
I don't know if I can shoot this out
everything okay
yep I'm great
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]